SOME SAY THE MODERATE LAMB WON
AFTER RUNNING LIKE A REPUBLICAN.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US ABOUT
MIDTERM ELECTIONS TO COME?
LET'S GET REACTION FROM
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN TOM PEREZ.
YOU HEARD SPEAKER RYAN TALKING
ABOUT THIS RACE AND HIS TAKE.
YOUR REACTION AND WHAT YOU TAKE
FROM THIS RACE EVEN THE
REPUBLICANS ARE CONTESTING TO
SAY THEY MAY STILL WON.
>> I THINK THIS RACE IS OVER.
MR. SACCONE CAN CONTESTED BUT
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR CONOR LAMB IS
GOING TO BE THE NEXT MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FROM THAT DISTRICT.
WHEN I HEAR SPEAKER RYAN TALK
ABOUT IT, HERE'S THE REALITY.
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IS
HEALTH CARE IN THE DISTRICT.
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE HEALTH CARE IS
A RIGHT FOR ALL AND NOT A
PRIVILEGE FOR FUEL.
WE HAVE SEEN REPEATED EFFORTS TO
MAKE IT HARD FOR PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH OPIOID ADDICTION
TO GET ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
THE HEALTH CARE VOTER CAME OUT
IN FORCE.
THEY WERE SUPPORTING CONOR LAMB.
SIMILARLY, THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE MINE WORKERS WHO
ARE LOSING THEIR PENSIONS.
THEY HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
THEM.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HASN'T BEEN
DOING A DARN THING FOR THEM.
CONOR LAMB WAS FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHT TO ORGANIZE, FIGHTING TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAD A GOOD WAGE
AND PENSION SECURITY.
HE WAS FIGHTING FOR ISSUES THAT
ARE CORE TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THAT'S WHY HE WON.
>> Bret: ARE THERE ENOUGH
CONOR LAMBS TO WIN CONSERVATIVE
DISTRICTS LIKE THIS IN THE
MIDTERMS AHEAD LIKE YOU DID IN
2006.
>> MORE COMPETITIVE THAN THE
DISTRICT YESTERDAY.
SENATOR FLAKE SAID IT WAS A
20-POINT MARGIN FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
IF I AM A REPUBLICAN, I AM
WORRIED.
DEMOCRATS ARE FIRED UP.
WE ARE ORGANIZING EVERYWHERE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES
PEOPLE CARE THE MOST ABOUT.
>> Bret: IF DEMOCRATS WIN THE
HOUSE, IS NANCY PELOSI THE
SPEAKER?
>> THAT WILL BE UP TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Bret: DON'T THESE
CANDIDATES, LIKE CONOR LAMB, RAN
AWAY FROM NANCY PELOSI HAVE TO
SAY THEY WOULDN'T VOTE FOR HER.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT CONOR
LAMB SAID, THAT'S CORRECT.
HERE'S THE THING ABOUT THE 18TH
DISTRICT, WHEN YOUR ONLY
ARGUMENT, THIS IS WHEN IT CAME
DOWN TO FOR CONOR LAMB'S
OPPONENT, HE IS GOING TO SUPPORT
NANCY PELOSI WHICH HE SAID HE
WASN'T, THAT'S A WEAK ARGUMENT.
WHAT VOTERS WANT TO KNOW IN
PENNSYLVANIA IS, ARE YOU GOING
TO HELP FIGHT FOR HEALTH CARE?
ARE YOU GOING TO HELP FIGHT FOR
MY PENSION SECURITY AND GOOD
JOBS?
THEY HEARD NOTHING FROM THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE.
THEY HAD NO MESSAGE, AND WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE BREAD AND
BUTTER ISSUES.
>> Bret: THERE IS NO DOUBT
THIS WAS A BIG MOMENT FOR
DEMOCRATS IN THIS DISTRICT.
WHY IS THE DNC HAVING A TOUGH
TIME FUND-RAISING?
>> WE RAISED MORE MONEY LAST
YEAR, BRET, THEN 2015.
WHEN I CAME IN, WE ARE BASICALLY
SHUT DOWN.
I DIDN'T GET THERE UNTIL ROUGHLY
THE FIRST OF MARCH.
>> Bret: IF YOU LOOK AT
JANUARY COMPARED TO THE RNC, 6.1
, WHAT YOU SPEND, WHAT YOUR DEBT
IS.
IF YOU LOOK AT 2017 COMPARING
THE TWO, THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE DNC AND
RNC.
>> THE RNC HAS RETURNED OWNERS.
WE RAISE MONEY FROM THE
GRASSROOTS.
THE RNC OUT RAISE THE DNC TO NO
ONE.
IN 2006, WE WON THE HOUSE.
WE HAVE BEEN WINNING ELECTIONS
OVER THE COURSE OF 2017.
THIS IS NOT AN ABERRATION.
IT'S A TREND.
I THINK WE ARE WINNING BECAUSE
FRANKLY WHILE THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE OUT RAISES
US, THEY ARE MORALLY BANKRUPT.
THEY ARE INVESTING THE LIKES OF
ROY MOORE IN ALABAMA.
THEY HAD TO PUT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO THIS RACE
YESTERDAY.
JOE ARPAIO IN ARIZONA.
WHEN YOU FIELD CANDIDATES WERE
SO WEAK AND NOW THEY ARE GOING
TO SPEND A LOT OF MONEY ON THE
TRUMP LEGAL DEFENSE FUND.
MEANWHILE WE ARE SPENDING MONEY
ON ORGANIZING.
>> Bret: HOW DO YOU SQUARE THE
CIRCLE ABOUT DEMOCRATS LIKE
CONOR LAMB WHO ARE DIFFERENT
THAN WHERE THE PARTY OVERALL IS
HEADED?
IS THE UMBRELLA BIGGER AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR PRO-LIFE
DEMOCRATS?
>> YOU WANT SAID THEY WEREN'T.
IS IT NOW?
>> THAT IS NOT AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT.
HERE'S WHAT I LEARNED IN
POLITICS EARLY ON.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT UNITY, WE
SHOULD NEVER CONFUSE UNITY WITH
UNANIMITY.
I AM NOT SAYING EVERYONE HAS TO
AGREE WITH ME.
I AM PROUD OF THE PLATFORM OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT I
RESPECT THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE HONEST DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ON ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE.
I AM GOING TO BE WORKING HARD TO
GET BOB CASEY REELECTED AND
CONOR LAMB REELECTED.
I GUESS IN THE 17TH DISTRICT NOW
WHEN IT MOVES OVER.
THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
CONOR LAMB WAS ABLE TO SPEAK TO
THOSE ISSUES THAT FOLKS CARED
ABOUT.
>> Bret: WHO IS THE LEADER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
>> I THINK THERE ARE MANY
LEADERS.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE TODAY WHO WERE
MARCHING ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY
ARE INCREDIBLE LEADERS.
I THINK WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
LEADING THE RESISTANCE HAVE BEEN
REMARKABLE LEADERS.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE MAYORS,
GOVERNORS, FOLKS HERE IN
CONGRESS.
THAT'S WHY I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE GOING.
>> Bret: ONE OF THOSE WOMEN
SPOKE OUT IN INDIA OVER THE
WOMEN, HILLARY CLINTON SAYING
SHE WANTS PLACES THAT ARE
OPTIMISTIC, DIVERSE, DYNAMIC,
MOVING FORWARD.
AND THAT TRUMPS CAMPAIGN WAS
LOOKING FORWARD.
DIDN'T LIKE BLACK PEOPLE GETTING
RIGHTS, YOU DON'T LIKE WOMEN
GETTING JOBS, YOU DON'T LIKE TO
SEE INDIAN AMERICAN SUCCEEDING.
WHATEVER YOUR PROBLEM IS, I'M
GOING TO SOLVE IT.
SHE WENT ON TO SAY THAT
ESSENTIALLY WHITE WOMEN WHO WERE
GOING TO VOTE FOR ME AND
STANDING UP TO THE MEN IN THEIR
LIVES AND THE MEN IN THEIR
WORKPLACES WERE BEING TOLD, SHE
IS GOING TO JAIL.
YOU DON'T WANT TO VOTE FOR HER.
SO MEN WERE TELLING WOMEN HOW TO
VOTE.
DO YOU AGREE WITH
HILLARY CLINTON AND HOW SHE
PHRASED THIS ELECTION?
>> DONALD TRUMP IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, ALTHOUGH
HILLARY CLINTON WON THE
MAJORITY, WON MORE VOTES THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
HE WON THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
SHE WON THE POPULAR VOTE.
I EXCEPT HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING IS
LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE WE
LEARN FROM OUR MISTAKES OF THE
PAST.
ONE OF OUR MISTAKES IT -- IS WE
NEED TO ORGANIZE EVERYWHERE.
WE NEED TO ARTICULATE WHAT WE
STAND FOR.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN
PENNSYLVANIA WITH CONOR LAMB.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
BREAD-AND-BUTTER ISSUES PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT.
>> Bret: YOU DON'T CONOR LAMB
WOULD --
>> WE WEREN'T FIELDING A
CANDIDATE.
WE LOST DISTRICT 18, THE MARGIN
WAS SOMETHING LIKE 70,000 VOTES,
WHICH EXCEEDED THE ENTIRE MARGIN
THERE WAS A SHAME ON US MOMENT
AS DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE FLOODING THE
ZONE, FIELDING GREAT CANDIDATES
EVERYWHERE SO WE CAN COMPETE
EVERYWHERE.
I THINK OUR MESSAGE RESONATES